[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
dave chappelle was attacked during his
set at the hollywood bowl last night
during the netflix is a joke comedy
festival welcome to the third episode of
the joke world podcast my name is jake
i'm your host today usually we have
guests on the podcast but this happened
last night it's one of the biggest
things happening comedy right now i'd
rather talk about this i think you'd
rather hear about this and we'll save
our new guest episode for next wednesday
new episodes every wednesday but no
further ado let's get right into this
let's play the footage first so we all
know what we're talking about dave
chappelle attacked tackled assaulted
with a deadly weapon potentially last
night during his stand-up show let's see
what this video is all about this one is
from tmz i think it gave the best view
behind me on the dj table is one of the
most prolific
producers that hip hop has ever
presented the mighty so right now he's
bringing up
he's bringing up a musician it was the
end of his set almost an hour and after
he's bringing up the next musical act
make some noise for hip-hop history
[Applause]
first of all what a terrible terrible
tackle i played football for many years
i played football in college i loved the
game been around for a while this is a
shitty forum tackle how are you not
going to be able to knock someone
completely off their feet that's not
expecting to get tackled dude it's not
like
dave chappelle knew
someone was about to run out he got a
stiff arm he got a juke he got a spin
move in the this dude had a a perfect
lined up dude it's like a receiver
catching a screen looking this way this
dude could have blasted him like that
reggie bush play uh when he was on the
saints against the eagles that's one of
the best hits on youtube look that up
reggie bush gets lit up but for real
dude this guy couldn't he he dave gets
like three or four back steps in then
falls down then immediately gets up
we'll keep running the play but what a
shitty tackle what a terrible form
tackle from an analytical standpoint
from a football perspective this guy
sucks he's not getting drafted he cannot
make it in the league there's no place
for this guy in comedy or the nfl let's
keep going
[Applause]
okay so now he's running away
that scary guard slipped
dave's running around
slow-mo
all right so he's on the stage he's
coming
dave braces
look at that he leaves his feet you
never leave your feet you have to keep
the feet driving leaves both of his feet
okay
so now now they're they look like
they're trying to corral them
i am going to kill them
chappelle said he's going to kill him
someone comes
now dave is going back to beat this
guy's ass himself he's jogging back to
the crowd and there's like 20 dudes just
stomping on this guy right now
what a mistake dude what a cut
how do you sit through the whole show
in the very end just ruin your life dude
it would be kind of cool to get beat up
by dave chappelle though
you know all the people that could beat
you up dave chappelle would be a cool
guy to look up while you're getting
stomped on and be like holy [ __ ] it's
the goat
oh [ __ ] it's chris rock oh [ __ ] it's
jamie foxx all these all the openers
came in everyone got a stomp on them
everyone got a lick on them
let's keep going
all right so now they're just beating
his ass
thank god
and chapelle's just making jokes
and they're still beating his ass
he's back there getting stumped
so he got stomped
[Applause]
where
probably still making jokes during all
of this
okay here comes jamie foxx
with this wheel thank you son
thing wrong side
it wasn't
he was a trans man
he said it was a trans man so that's
that makes not to add i mean
i'm not rooting for this [ __ ] that
attack but not to add any insult to
injury literally but it's got to suck
knowing that your big moment was running
onto the stage you're going to attack
dave chappelle you're going to
prove whatever point you're trying to
make and not only did you completely
whiff on your tackle
which is embarrassing but also then his
whole crew 20 plus people is just
beating the [ __ ] out of you
and you have to hear that chappelle's
still going on making even probably
better jokes in his whole set about you
like it was complete failure dude not to
add insult to literal injury but while
you're in the hospital while you're in
the ambulance getting taken away looking
like tom segura after the dunk contest
with your arm you know behind your head
dave chappelle's calling you a trans man
and and making the audience laugh more
than he ever did like like that's got to
be not more than ever did but like
that's gotta that's gotta suck that you
didn't even like disrupt the show
you know
like that's like if on 911 they [ __ ]
hit one tower and everyone kept working
while it was falling it's like you
didn't even affect anything that might
not be the best analogy but dude okay so
let's read this article let's get to the
very bottom of this i want to figure out
who this guy was why he did this what he
was possibly thinking what the
repercussions are going to be what
happened to him what's happening with
dave everything and it's funny that
chris rock was happened to be at the
show because
i knew after the will smith thing
happened a lot of people were saying did
this just accidentally open the door up
you know to to every every comedian
getting attacked and assaulted on stage
and i i don't think that's true but look
i mean less than two months later and
and the goat is getting tackled also a
lot of people during that will smith
thing were saying i bet he would have
done this to dave chappelle what if this
was dave chappelle not chris rock chris
rock's a little smaller um
but this is different because it was a
random audience member not like a movie
star you know not a not a celebrity like
will smith so okay comedian this is from
page six dot com so some real
some real like there's there's like a
hundred ads on this website like i am
just [ __ ] up my searches going on
this trash you know tmz kind of news
website but comedian dave chappelle was
attacked on stage by audience member
armed with a fake gun that had a real
knife inside tuesday night at hollywood
bowl authorities say
so he
he had a the the guy that attacked him
had a fake gun
with a real
knife
hidden
inside was it like a bayonet like like
civil war gun with a knife on the end
but it was a fake it was oh no this is
fake like it's fine
they're like sir you can't bring guns in
here no weapons and he's like oh don't
worry this is i just can't understand
why you would try to sneak in
your knife
in a vessel that is so much more
um illegal and and then the knife is
like that's like if you were trying to
like
it's like if you were trying to like
bring like weed on an airplane or
something and to get past security
you like hid the bud in like a bag of
cocaine and you're a fake bag of cocaine
and the security guard's like uh what is
this you're like oh no no no no that's
that's fake coke so it's fine and what
and don't look like you're bringing a
knife inside a fake gun that's like if
you went to a bar tried to sneak alcohol
into a outside alcohol in a bar i don't
know if any of you have ever been so
poor that you bring your own alcohol to
a bar but sometimes you gotta sneak a
few uh tall boys in your jacket but
that's like if if you went into a bar
trying to sneak in a bottle of tito's
and instead of just hiding it somewhere
around your body you hit it inside a
case of beer
like neither of these things are allowed
in
why are you why are you trying to
smuggle something and that's something
so much worse dude this guy
this might be the stupidest man in
america let's keep reading
the comic david 48 was performing at
netflix as a joke festival when the
mayhem unfolded around 10 45 p.m towards
the end of the stand-up show according
to witnesses
okay so yeah that like it was towards
the end of the show he was bringing up
the next musical act
um
[Music]
it's just so strange because obviously
this wasn't planned like a lot of people
and we'll get to this i posted in the
community section so we're going to read
some comments
from you guys about what you think of
this but a lot of people were saying
that like you know if you can't handle
the jokes
don't go to a comedy show but this seems
so
um
like pre-planned like uh
premeditated
because he obviously brought he had the
genius idea to sneak in the knife and
the fake gun you know we're dealing with
a real onsen here but this is like why
why i just don't get if you hated dave
chappelle so much that you're going to
pre-meditate and attack on him with a
deadly weapon
why you would
sit through an hour of his show dude
maybe that just that just you know shows
the the greatness of dave chappelle that
no even the people that hate him
you know if they pay for that ticket
they're gonna at least see the show
first before they try to [ __ ] kill
him
um
shocking video shows chappelle standing
on stage as an audience member
identified by authorities as isaiah lee
23 years old wow charges and slams him
to the floor
i don't think he really slammed in the
floor like i said that
if dave spelled a football on him they
would need to gang tackle him dude dave
is a tank
seconds later the attacker was tackled
by security
oh also
can we get maybe some security on the
front
front of these stages
like they did a better job than the
oscars you know at least at least this
guy didn't get to sit
go back to a seat and then sit there
then get brought on stage later
at least isaiah lee didn't get an award
20 minutes after he tackled dave
chappelle but where is the security like
in the front
in the front of the stage like maybe we
could try to stop
stop the attacker before they reach the
comedian that's an insane idea but
i feel like they would feel more
protected
if
the threats were neutralized before
physical contact
there's been a lot of um i don't know if
you're watching the nba playoffs but um
there was there's at the timberwolves
games there's these crazy [ __ ] that
keep like
running on the floor they try to glue
herself on the floor and
tie herself to the hoop or
i don't really know what that's all
about or or why people are protesting
the timberwolves they they're terrible
organization as it is it's enough
punishment to be the timberwolves but
like those secured those nba security
guards in minnesota
there's videos of them like tackling
there was one where this lady started
running over the bleachers and she's
already on the floor
getting pinned down with like within two
steps on the court
what's going on here
oh wow somebody's run onto the floor
beverly
why is there no security on the front
let's keep reading
lee who lives in los angeles was
arrested for felony assault with a
deadly weapon
that's so bad dude imagine just a tackle
just just a tackle
but because of your
genius idea to sneak the gun in with the
knife and the fake gun and the blade now
it's assault with a deadly weapon
lapd spokes person said the suspect was
carrying a replica handgun
with a blade inside
[ __ ] idiot lee was taken to the
hospital before he was booked early
wednesday into jail on a 30 dollar bail
authorities say
it's unclear what provoked the attack
yeah you couldn't ask him
23 year old attacking dave chappelle if
i had to guess i would say it's some
extremely misguided
woke young kid who thinks he's saving
the world because dave chappelle is
funny and you know those people can't
really handle humor that well
and i i just why would you do that why
would you do that that has to be the
only reason right
like chappelle joked and said that was a
trans man
which is hilarious obviously because
he's in
all the hot water with that community
following the incident chappelle
appeared to carry on with the show
in a video shared with social media
chapelle joked about the attacker it was
trans man hilaire told the audience i
don't know if that was part of the show
i grabbed the back of that dude's head
his hair was spongy absorbent the
attacker was later taken to a hospital
after sustaining injuries and these
injuries were significant i i i already
called him tom segura after the don
contest but that's literally what it
looked like dude his elbow was facing
the opposite way we'll put an image in
right now but
it was grotesque it was not a good
scene dude that is hilarious instant
karma i don't know if you could think of
a better situation
that that could
represent instant karma like you
you rush dave chappelle
you miss the tackle
you get charged with
assault with a deadly weapon even though
you didn't use it and then
four legendary comedians plus 15
security guards all literally beat the
[ __ ] out of you in front of the audience
while then chappelle is still going on
making jokes about you
and how much of a failure you are at
being a piece of [ __ ] dude this guy is
was trying to be a piece of [ __ ] and
failed at that what a okay so
in one twitter video the suspect is seen
lying on a stretcher with his elbow
facing the other way
a man charged and tackled chappelle just
as the show is ending according to a
tweet from brianna sax a buzzfeed
journalist who was there
brianna sax nice she said security rush
and started punching and kicking the
[ __ ] out chappelle's attacker
all right let's watch this video of him
getting taken off
this tweet is from sax it's from
bsax
and it says just came out of the
hollywood bowl where a man charged and
tackled depaul on stage and got his ass
kicked by at least 10 people lapd and
lafd are now loading him into an
ambulance
hey back up
[Music]
[Music]
he's getting into the ambulance boo
boo that's the best you can come on
hey you boo
dude
that's got to feel weird for the
paramedics because i would imagine
they're usually pretty sympathetic
to the people that they're picking up
but this guy was just being a jackass
and then got the instant karma
how often do you think that while
they're taking oh no my screen went out
and if you know if you've been following
this channel you know that
i have real screen issues with this one
i'm gonna put it back after i make this
point how many times do you think these
people have been loading someone in an
ambulance to the to the sound of booze
from a crowd like you're saving their
life and everyone's like [ __ ] that guy
boo
i wonder if they were booing the
paramedics for helping them maybe they
weren't even booing the guy all right
time to fix the screen
in another video chappelle thanked jamie
foxx for rushing to help him saying
listen i just want to say i've had an
incredible time what a professional i've
been doing this for 35 years i just
stomped a dude backstage always wanted
to do that
dude
davidson fell bad ass
chris rock handled handled the oscars
like a professional
sorry
that's about as as um
calm
sorry and professional it's the florida
man beer 8.5
not to brag
it's a double ipa um
chris rock was
as professional i think as you could get
at the oscars for a comedian being
assaulted
on stage kept the show going obviously
that's a way different situation your
audience is a bunch of hollywood elite
that
don't have your back
um
a lot of people i know on flagrant too
andrew schultz a lot of people were
not calling chris rock out but maybe
being like
dude how do you not you know
stand up for yourself a little bit or at
least
i don't know a lot of people were saying
that that chris rock me not i'm not
calling him a [ __ ] but he he he didn't
handle it
um
in an aggressive manner because he was
worried about his career he's in this
big hollywood production
and it was great for him because he's
still gonna he only benefited from being
slapped you know he didn't retaliate and
that was that was the move for where
he's at
but this is a stand-up festival this is
what this was at the netflix is a joke
festival which was in this last week and
still going on in los angeles
a ton of huge names performing there by
the way obviously dave chappelle
and so this is an audience full of
stand-up fans
and isaiah lee 23 years old with the
fake gun um
and b sack from
wherever she's from
where's she from what news entity
buzzfeed i feel like a lot of buzzfeed
journalists aren't the biggest
supporters of comedy but i anyway
i like how chappelle handled it so much
more than i like how chris rock handled
it i know that those are different
situations
but it's so much uh more satisfying to
me and so much like
it's sending a such different message to
people that
might be stupid enough
so like literally so bricks for brains
enough to like try this at a different
show
this set such a precedent snapping this
dude's arm in half and having the the
comedian that he attacked stomp his ass
out plus all of his crew and all the
security
and then him to like make fun of this
dude and joke about it and i know that
it's a different situation but i just
for comedy's sake
for being a fan of chappelle and for the
safety of comedians moving forward like
i just love how this was handled so much
more too because it didn't even ruin the
show also like he made
some jokes about the thing happening
he's completely fine this dude is [ __ ]
he didn't get to accept an award after
he's going to go to jail for assault
with a deadly weapon like and and he has
his arm is just like literally almost
dangling off
holding on by a thread so i'm just so
happy
that they almost killed this guy
it would have been great maybe for a one
or two day coma that would have really
sent the message and that would have
almost ensured you know this this
doesn't happen any comics moving forward
so i guess my only thing to say to dave
chappelle is like
maybe go a little harder for the one or
two day coma
i don't want this guy to get killed
however he did charge you with a a fake
gun and i know that can be very dude
what are you even gonna
like what are you even gonna do with a
fake gun
like
on a state like i guess if you were like
in the street and you had a fake gun
you're like give me your money and they
think it's real then they do it but if
you're on a stage
and it's fake so you can't actually kill
them so you're holding up
the comedian dave chappelle
like
hey
tell a pro trans joke like what what is
i don't know he didn't even use it so i
guess that makes sense but i just don't
get what your plan was with a fake gun
because if you can't actually kill him
if it doesn't shoot anything you're just
gonna hold it at towards point it at him
on a stage knowing that it doesn't work
and then just intimidate him into doing
what exactly
hey venmo me a million dollars on like
what where are you gonna where are you
gonna go what's your
i just don't get what his plan was i
don't get what his intent was maybe
we're gonna learn more this literally
happened last night and and i'm filming
this today
um
pretty much as soon as i could so i
guess we don't know all the info i just
don't get
literally the whole point of the fake
gun i guess for this dude was to bring
in
the knife inside of the it was literally
just like a smuggling container
which is so [ __ ] funny dude it's so
funny
i need to think of some more analogies i
think the weed and the airport one was
was pretty good if i do say so myself
but it's just so funny to sneak in
an illegal item in an even more illegal
item
it's like a pregnant mexican woman
coming to the united states you're
sneaking one in that was a good joke too
i just thought of that dude that was
pretty good all right if you like that
joke you have to give this video a like
oh also just so we know like
there's going to be guests after this
episode
um i just really wanted to to dive into
this situation because it's brand new
and it's developing and you know
long-term joke world uh one of my one of
my goals or visions for this brand would
be to
give comedy like a new source or a media
entity kind of like how sports has
bleacher report and espn and and stuff
where you can
follow every sport at once and all your
favorite athletes at once and get news
about what's going on with everything
all at once
i would love joke world to be able to
turn into that for commie so like you
know something like chris rock happens
and it's every comedian's reaction or
the giant depth thing or this thing or
you know just the compilations of best
moments between guys or try not to
laughs of all these different podcast
clips throughout the years um well i
think joke world's one of one of my main
visions for this moving forward would be
to be like this media
entity in the world of comedy you know
kind of like bar stool sports kind of
like
bleach report espn is is sports just
kind of like you know
some something that the people get to
control
it's from an outsider coming in and the
people get to control it it's fan
interactive and it is something that you
can stay up to date with everything
that's happening all at once for people
like us that just truly
you know love this [ __ ] just love stand
up and and comedians podcasts and just
laughing and and finding humor and and
touch your subjects or dark topics you
know edgy jokes and and free speech and
and these type of things these
communions that we cover
on our page in our videos they all have
a similar
sense of humor they're all in that same
category of you know
just uninformed stupid people on
instagram probably think that they're
bigots like
if you went up to some random you know
like college age girl and started
talking about the joe rogan experience i
feel like just because of bots on
twitter and you know social media
brainwashing they'd be like oh only like
um
joe rogan that's for like white racists
right like it's and we know it's not
but like you know how the outside
opinion is of a lot of our favorite
comedians is because they're funny and
say funny [ __ ] and they don't bend to
the
sword of society and they don't you know
just start blowing woke people that
there's some there's for some reason
dangerous or something though those are
my kind of comedians those are your kind
of comedians if you're watching this um
i don't really even know where i got
going with this but
let's get back let's get back to the
matter at hand
defending dave chappelle's honor
okay
audience member judd simmons described
the evening as perfect before the attack
happened but noted venue security was
non-existent
okay
so
why
you know like why
yeah maybe
the most controversial
comedian currently in the world in dave
chappelle especially after that last
special which i thought was outstanding
and you're going to be like non-existent
security i'm sure
no one's going to rush the stage or
anything in fact
we checked everyone at the front and no
one even has any deadly weapons with
them one guy has this fake gun but it's
just a replica and there's probably
nothing inside
seemed like dave's entourage security
and crew dealt with the situation he
told the post chappelle came out and did
an amazing set for about an hour he was
just about to bring out a musical act
when some random guy in the front of us
or some random guy in the front of us in
the audience climbed the stage and
tackled dave it was surreal
it was also real elon musk walked by
right before it went down
that's super random
my
[ __ ] screen dude how long has it been
blue
someone tell me i hate the screen
i'm gonna finish this paragraph
it was also real and by the way someone
was like you gotta turn off the um
the sleep setting
on your on your laptop but then it'll
stay
on
the screen that you want and i did that
i don't know why it just keeps switching
over to this blue
this blue thing
and if you're only listening to the
podcast right now um go check it out on
youtube if you don't know what i'm
talking about with the screen and stuff
if you're only listening check it out
check us out on youtube every video or
every episode we'll have a full video on
there subscribe we have a lot of great
videos besides this podcast on there
like i just kind of touched on about
other videos compilations trying not to
laughs keeping you up to date
in the comedy world but
there's a screen behind me
with the podcast logo and and just some
other you know graphics and uh
it like keeps changing to like my home
blue screen
every like 10 minutes so
that's what's going on if you're just
listening and you're like i don't get
what what he's saying about the screen
like what does he mean about the screen
it's you just go on youtube and you'll
figure it out
okay
so i guess elon musk was there and
that's where we stopped
elon musk walked by right before it went
down then jamie foxx ran up there the
crowd was just shocked
when dave came back to the mic he kept
saying get that guy off stage because
the attacker was still on stage being
held down by 20 people
that was such a [ __ ] burp dude i
thought that was going to be an
outrageous just clanging burp and it
would have been such a good moment for
all of us to listen to
and instead it was the [ __ ] burp
of all time
dave handled the whole thing like a pro
just another reason why he's the goat
one audience member told the post the
crowd thought it was part of the show
um
i i don't know what what
it's actually he made some the you know
did the trans joke and and talked about
always want to stomp someone that it
might have seemed part of the show
because his material afterwards is so
well written but i don't know what
comedy show
includes
at the very end someone comes up and
tries to assault
the best communion of all time
with a deadly weapon
i'm just gonna say that was a stupid
thing to assume that it could be part of
the show
i never assumed it was part of this well
i wasn't there british comedian jimmy
carr rushed to twitter after the show
ended to share a selfie with chappelle
the comic described the standing show as
crazy after witnessing the attack
the hollywood bowl show with the
legendary dave chappelle was crazy just
happy everyone's okay he wrote alongside
this image
another audience member told the post he
was shocked and angered towards the
attacker it was just a dumb person
trying to do something stupid he told
the post
he somehow got by the initial security
but we've learned since then that the
security was non-existent
the comic found himself in hot water
last year over jokes about trans
community blah blah blah all right let's
watch one more video
this one was taken by someone that was
there
it's um
if you're just listening again
definitely go check this out but it is
a far away shot someone recorded on
their phone uh 30 seconds
thank you son
it was a
it was a trans man
[Laughter]
so
yeah
dave chappelle
attacked on stage
i'm sure we're gonna make some sort of
comp
compilation of uh
every comedian reacts to dave chappelle
being tackled
once everyone else's podcast come out
but
i don't know man
after the chris rock thing happened i i
would just kind of you know daydream if
i was on stage what i would do
in this situation
and
it seems obvious to me what my move
would be now i'm not a fighter
at all
anyone could beat me up in the world
if you see me
at any time in your life
you could beat me up if you wanted
however
if i am on stage
i have a
six to ten pound
metal microphone with a bulb on top of
its shape
that if i see and and i see you coming
and i'm elevated so here's what i
thought after the chris rock thing and
here is what i'm going to do if i'm ever
at some open mic and and someone
which would never happen but
i think the best move would just like
pop
you know hold hold the end of the mic
so the the microphone parts up here you
got the end base right right just like
this the guy is coming towards you you
wait you wait there with the mic in your
hand until he's about
a yard away
and then just with the heavy metal part
of it pop
right in the forehead pop
just like that
it'd make a funny sound because it's
mic'd up
it'd make a
dude and it wouldn't be a clap but it
would make a hilarious sound just
hitting this guy in the forehead
and it would hurt
so bad i would swing it so hard right in
the middle of your forehead just a huge
welt dude huge like a third eye your
third eye is coming out like a [ __ ]
mountain
that's the move dude if you're a
comedian
and someone's rushing your stage
pop them with the mic dude that it makes
a hilarious sound they're gonna probably
fall back this would be the best if they
got bopped
whoa stunned
i'm stunned i'm stunned ow ow and then
fell backwards off the stage onto their
back and then after that someone shot
them 10 times that would be
realistic
but yeah dave chappelle
assaulted stage
tackled
but he had some yards after contact his
yak
his yards after well that's yards after
catch his yards after contact is elite
if the draft just happened and they're
kind of picking up free agents right now
by the way i'm available but so is dave
chappelle
um broke it like a champ took it like a
champ
and
just like i feel like we knew chappelle
would if you told me dave chappelle was
tackled on stage what would he do after
my best guess would be make a few
hilarious jokes in the moment about what
just happened
and that's what he did so
i'm excited to learn more maybe about uh
what's his name isaiah lee's intentions
23 year old isaiah lee
i would love to get isaiah on the
podcast just to figure out what this
fake
fake
gun with a knife inside strategy
was um
i'd love to know some of his other
logical thoughts on life because i'm
sure they're hilarious you know i'm sure
he does a lot of things
kind of backwards if you thought the
best way to sneak a knife
into a show was through a gun
that i'm sure you have a lot of other
great life hacks that i i would just
find hilarious i'm kind of pissed off
dude because i can't
dude i can't even
i didn't have enough time to figure out
the funniest part about trying to sneak
a weapon inside a more illegal weapon um
but like there are some great jokes to
be written about this so if
if you want to steal this promise
go for it you know i think maybe my
my um
illegal immigrant
joke was my maybe my best try i don't
know this is i'm i'm going off the top
of my head dude this just happened last
night what do you want from me man
there's my lug again
also i'm sorry for wearing shorts in the
first episode when the camera had my
whole leg in it
actually me and matthew bursar were both
in shorts
and um
it is a lot of leg someone commented
that's that's a lot of leg and
i agree you don't want to see that much
male leg
you know
it'd be one thing
if two girls were on a podcast and they
were both wearing shorts but me and
matthew should have had pants on i
i agree with that you can't have
if you're if your legs have more than
four or five hairs on them
you can't go on a podcast and shorts and
i did it again just now but i also
thought that i would keep it from
the waist up and for the fifth time if
you're just watching this on or if
you're just listening this on your phone
check out the youtube video and you'll
know what i'm talking about with the
legs or don't if you don't like male
legs which i'm sure most of you don't uh
then don't check out the video but also
still do obviously because i need you to
check out
the video
so that's um the main thing that i want
to talk about today is just get to the
bottom of this
chappelle thing with you i also posted
this on the community section the first
this was the first thing i saw when i
woke up this morning was that all this
[ __ ] happened and then i immediately
went to
our community section where that's one
of my favorite parts about this channel
and i think that's one of the things
that this channel does
differently than others is
you know at least once a day but but
more often more than that is just
posting stuff in our community section
for people
to interact with like
you know everyone wants to sound off on
because we all love we all love this
dude if you're listening in past 30
minutes of the joke world podcast
then it's confirmed that you love this
art dude you love comedy and you love
laughing and you love
you know this
it feels like we're almost the last
frontier of people that that can speak
their mind and make people laugh and say
things just for joke's sake you know so
many people want to
rip people apart for for jokes and for
their senses of humor and
you know there's there's times where
people want to even make you feel bad
about liking
comedians that they don't
agree with their viewpoints even though
viewpoints is in quotation marks because
most jokes that comedians are telling
are just for the laugh effect or the
drama effect like these these [ __ ]
idiots don't even understand that these
aren't real viewpoints and and
i know we all get that i'm preaching i'm
literally preaching to the choir right
now because if you're listening this
right now then then i i know that you
get it
but
i don't know dude like
it's just it's just nice to cultivate
this safe community of people with the
same
senses of humor and same you know core
not beliefs it's not a [ __ ] cult but
it's like
you get what i'm saying and the
community page is is really fun you get
to vote on stuff you get to watch new
videos you get to vote on stupid things
like i put a pull-up who's going to win
the nba finals you also get to vote on
fun things like who would your dream you
know line up tour lineup b name three
convenience open middle and and headline
like it's just a cool cool section that
community page and um
i'm sure most of you have seen it but i
posted dave chappelle tackled on stage
last night question mark question mark
exclamation yada that was three hours
ago
when i posted it so there's only 26
comments so far i'm sure there will be a
lot more um
by the time you see this later today and
in the weeks to come and a lot more is
going to come out about this chapel this
is just the fir by the way
um
if you're tired of hearing about this
already like tough luck because this is
the first
day
that this is news like it became news
late last night this is the first full
day that this is news
and it's going to
dominate
our social media lives people that are
into stand it's going to dominate for a
while
just probably exactly like the chris
rock thing
which actually wasn't that long i feel
like what was that like two weeks
of mayhem
which is long for a story in the united
states actually i mean around here we
pay attention for something for a few
hours
no matter how serious it is it could be
the most serious thing in the world you
get maybe two hours of attention before
we get we're on to the next story
um so that chris rocking did stay in the
news for a while and i feel like this
will be maybe a little less but
similar
for us but anyway post it in the
community section and i just want to
read a few of your comments um
because these are the these you guys are
the people
listening to this show and and
supporting this channel so i it's
important that your voice is heard
because this is
the vibe of of our whole community i
just feel like joke world is just one
entity you know it's all
85 000 of us and um
what you guys have to say about this is
equally if not more important than what
i have to say about this i'm just one
person you guys are the the comedy
masters if you want to you know put your
finger on the pulse of comedy of what
people are feeling of of who people are
feeling
then
i think the joke world uh subscribers
section i think these the people that
[ __ ] with us the this is a great
um
source of of how people feel about
issues in comedy or how people are
reacting to a situation like this
so i think it's
more important than what i have to say
is what you guys have to say and they're
all there's only 26 comments let me
refresh me we got one more now there's
only 26 comments so far
um but this is when we're recording so
these are the ones we're eating
all right
the first comment 18 likes it's our
number one comment and it's got four
replies
yurkick said dude tackled him on stage
and dave's security team jimmy fox chris
rock and dave himself beat the dog [ __ ]
out of the dude they ta the tackle was
horrible
but the beat down was magnificent
i'm not honestly that happy that the guy
got the [ __ ] kicked out of him but it
needs to happen if he thought he was
going to rush the stage tackling dave
[ __ ] chappelle and walking away like
nothing happened
first of all i'm so sorry for struggling
through that sentence um maybe it's the
florida man maybe this was worded a
weird way maybe it's a little bit of
both but
yeah
one of my favorite parts about this oh
dude i didn't even say this yet
i don't think that there's video of this
but apparently
apparently
apparently there's been
multiple reports that after this all
happened chris rock who opened the show
dude what are the odds that chris rock
was opening this show
but he he was an opener he was on a
lineup the show was called dave
chappelle and friends was the
so in these comedy festivals i just got
back from the moon tower comedy festival
that's where we interviewed hans kim at
and austin got to see a ton of great
live performances made some good
connections there and it was honestly
one of the coolest things in the world
dude like
thursday through sunday
starting at four o'clock and then going
till two or three in the morning i i had
this pass and i could just go around and
just watch
stand up for hours and hours and hours
hour like eight hours of stand up at
night
four nights in a row
you know just legends up there dude it
was awesome but
that was the moon tower comedy festival
in austin
this last week um was the netflix is a
joke festival in california another one
i i wanted to go to but i just got back
from austin i was like what
what am i going to just keep you know
festival [ __ ]
no not not me not not jake
so um
i keep forgetting what i was saying um
oh the way that these festivals are are
you know formatted is
it's just like you get this map and then
there's a bunch of different shows
happening at the same time all around
the city and their own name different
things so i went to a few um
you know stand up on the spots with
jeremiah
the goddamn comedy jam
which if my grandma's listening to this
i did not say i didn't say the goddamn
comedy jam i didn't add that part it's
all that's the name of it i'm just
saying the name of it
and that was my favorite thing in the
world dude josh adam if you don't if
you've never heard of this look up josh
adam myers on instagram right now and
look up the goddamn comedy jam it is the
best thing in the world
in the world dude my my friends my
girlfriend everyone's begging me to stop
talking about it since i've got back
from austin but i literally can't dude i
literally can't i it it's amazing it's
it's our favorite comedians just jamming
out to like it's almost like karaoke
with a real like live band behind them
and everyone's standing up but it's like
comedians like big j okarson like just
shredding and just and singing these
just amazing songs and and people are
crowds comedians are crowd surfing and
it it's
just look it up on instagram right now
the goddamn comedy jam i can't speak
highly enough about it i try to get an
interview with josh adam meyers the guy
that runs this after well while i was in
austin after i went to this show three
times um unfortunately he had to leave
like the morning that i
i hit him up at like
like two in the morning after one of the
shows and he was like i would but we
have to leave
like at like 6 a.m so we had there was
no even studio time but
one day i would i will get him on and it
will be
splendid and my camera is about to die
if any if there's a weird pause but
anyway the way that these things are set
up these festivals is you can just go
around
and see all these different shows so
this show was called dave chappelle and
friends and some of the friends were
jamie foxx and some of the friends were
chris rock
and apparently after this happened after
his altercation happened chris rock came
back on stage gave dave gave dash
chris rock came on stage gave dave
chappelle a hug
and then said into the mic was that will
smith
amazing amazing
job at chris rock it's almost a layup of
a joke i feel like it's very obvious but
the fact that he said it
it almost kind of makes up for not doing
anything while it actually happened him
at the oscars okay we're back with a
fresh camera battery sorry about those
technical difficulties back to your
comments in the comment section based
off of the dave chapelle getting tackled
on stage last night
this guy said yeah dude broke his hand
or arm dave was fine
and someone responded said his entire
arm was bent backwards and shoulder out
of place he got [ __ ] up correction
both hands broken and arm dislocated
so that is that is great to hear dude i
i mean i've never been happier about
just someone being completely you know
dismembered
in front of a live audience
this is some real like roman time stuff
you know just like
tearing this guy apart like chewbacca in
front of
3 000 people
um i wish i could have been there man i
wish i could have been
one of the people that got a stomping a
kick
swift kick to the side would have felt
really good
man
i'm just jealous of the people
that got to hurt this guy
damn
thank god for jamie foxx we almost lost
a good one
there's a lot of stuff on the stage that
you could use you got the stool you
could that's four pointed you could you
could do something with that um maybe
have a drink that you could throw in the
face we need to start maybe getting a
little more crafty on the comedian side
with our self-defense tactics um
i'm still you know waiting for someone
to rush one of rogan's stages i would
love to see
some sort of crazy ass black belt arm
bar or you know choke out and i think
that would be really fun maybe a kick
kick to the head
that could be cool so please try to rush
joe rogan's stage um
just for our own entertainment it would
actually do
great numbers on the channel so if you
are a local idiot in any of the places
that joe rogan is going to perform this
is a bad idea i this i shouldn't be
on camera
[Laughter]
telling people to go attack joe that's
not what i mean i'm just saying it would
be great content
after the fact not for you you would be
[ __ ]
but for me and for everyone else to
enjoy
um you comedy fans you got nothing else
to do this is coming out on wednesday uh
this weekend coming up
if you're looking to get into some good
stand up uh joe list just dropped a
special on youtube it's excellent joe
list um from
you've seen them all around youtube
obviously uh comedian for a long time
co-hosts of tuesday's stories i don't
have to tell you to list this but this
but the the the special is fantastic um
chris stefano especially weshy
on netflix that is also out now another
fantastic one for you to watch so that's
a few hours of comedy for you guys this
weekend if you're into either of those
two guys if you've never heard of them
which i doubt i would go give them a
chance
christina p is coming out with
her her special on netflix very soon as
well i forget the date i think it is
around may
early may so so be on the lookout for
that
be on the lookout for new joke world
videos we're posting about three a week
um at this point
um so make sure you look out for that
we're gonna put together a every
comedian's react to elon musk's buying
twitter video soon we're gonna probably
um put together a every comedian reacts
to this dave chappelle situation soon
and then just a lot of other good stuff
coming up the pipe perhaps a
new york
comedian compilation maybe a new york
versus l.a compilation a lot of good
stuff coming up don't want to ruin all
the don't want to you know show my full
hand here
or spoil all these new videos but
a lot of promising things coming up
thank you for listening to the joke
world podcast this is
really fun for me to do um to get to you
know communicate and talk with you guys
and see what you guys are feeling about
you know the comedy world and to
be
you know really the only podcast that's
talking about
comedy um
all these other podcasts that we love
are by comedians
with comedians on them
and they're very successful high level
comedians you know and i think that for
you know the real comedy nerds of the
world that just love
you know some ins and outs
um this podcast is about comedy it's it
it might not be a
comedy podcast where you're supposed to
laugh the whole time and there's bits
and there's segments and there's all
right now we're reading now we're
getting call-ins and you know unhelpful
advice or whatever it's not really gonna
be a bitty
bitty show or like a segmented show but
it's it's a show about comedy and it's a
show about standup and it's a show about
the comedians that we love and stay up
to date with them and see what's going
on with them so um i really appreciate
you guys making this into a viable
product i think it'd be it's something
that's missing in the space in my
opinion there's there there isn't
something like this for us people that
like to you know in these interviews
i've done so far whether it's with hans
kim or with matthew matthew broussard or
the interviews that are to come that are
still being released um
there's a lot of ins and outs and a lot
of inside baseball if you will a lot of
technicalities about stand-up and how
you write a set and how you maneuver an
audience and and how you think on the
fly and do these kind of things and go
on different shows and what your writing
process is like and these are things
that you know you're not going to hear
on this past weekend or the joe rogan
experience or
um you know
manchester pockets or whatever you want
to say
it is like the this is
this podcast is kind of a look behind
the curtain if you will um to the real
technicalities of what comedy is or what
professional
comedy is so
i appreciate you guys like you know
making this a thing because i can sit
here and ramble on
until i'm blue in the face button unless
you guys are liking these videos and
still subscribing and listening and
downloading them on spotify and apple
and wherever you play you listen um it's
not a thing it's only a thing with you
guys so just want to say thank you again
thank you for sitting through a solo
episode
shout out to dave chappelle shout out to
um not shout out to the [ __ ]
security at netflix's joke comedy
festival
netflix you are one of the richest
organizations
around probably not in the world but
around you can hire some better security
dave chappelle seems like he could
hire some more security too but then he
wouldn't have got to get his fair stop
in the game so
nothing more to say about this
thank you for listening please subscribe
follow us on instagram if you want some
free joke world stickers and i will see
you next wednesday
[Music]
you